[MUSIC PLAYING]
SWAROOP KUMAR: AppOn
is based out of Pune,
and we started in 2012.
We make games which
are easy to explain,
optimized for the
emerging markets.
With such a tremendous
acceptance of the smartphone,
we have to focus on this markets
to maximize our revenues.
They hold a great deal of
business opportunities for us.
VAIBHAV HEMNE: So Kitchen Story
is a simulation casual game
and resource skill
management game.
So you have to cook
different dishes
and compete with different
world-class chef.
When the Kitchen Story was at
the conceptual level itself,
we had keeping in mind
that whatever we make,
we make it under 20 MB.
In India, basically,
there are plenty
of challenges that we face.
One of them is the
device compatibilities.
Second is their
data [INAUDIBLE]..
Third is the low-performing
devices and the language
support.
So one must make
sure that the game is
built for all the
kind of devices
and the performance should
be same on all the devices,
whether it's a high-end
device or a low-end device.
SWAROOP KUMAR: We learned
from our past mistakes
that developing
[INAUDIBLE] a game heavier
is going to be disastrous
for these countries,
so you are actually motivated
to make a game which is
already lighter in the files.
Working with Google, we found
out the best possible ways
to keep the game size smallest.
The first one would be to
use a Noto fonts instead
of using custom
fonts, as it reduces
the size of the applications,
and it's very easy
to translate your games
in other languages.
VAIBHAV HEMNE: Second
of all, native shapes
are useful for animations,
UI, and effects.
So if you use
native shapes, that
helps to reduce the
game size drastically,
and to make sure that while
reducing the game size,
we do not compromise
on UI and UX.
SWAROOP KUMAR: I would
say use color tables.
The images like
metrics of the colors,
where you can stack the color
tables and their indexes
separately.
Then, you just change
the color table
and you have altogether
different image.
We made the game to work
in the offline mode,
because in India, not everyone
has the internet connectivity
all the time.
We also shifted over a lot of
the game data or game assets
to on the cloud.
VAIBHAV HEMNE: Up to now, we've
got almost 6 million downloads
and over 100,000 reviews
with a rating of 4.4.
SWAROOP KUMAR: The
initial retentions
are really high because the
game is very easy to learn,
so the Day 1 retentions
are up to 60%.
We always are focused on
making a lighter, faster game
with having a great
user experience.
Now, all these techniques which
we have been using so far,
and now, it has become
the part of our DNA.
And we do follow these
techniques in our newer games.